Welcome back to The Explainer. So, last
time we set the stage.
We looked at Elizabeth's background, her
character, and all the glitz and glamour
of her royal court. But today, we're
diving into the absolute nitty-gritty.
This is the second topic of your
Elizabethan England revision, and we're
going to uncover the political engine room
that kept her entire regime running day to
day. We're talking about her key
ministers, Cecil, Walsingham, and the
all-important Privy Council. Let's get
into it.
Here's our game plan for today. We'll
start with the Queen's engine room, then
move on to William Cecil the manager,
Walsingham the spy master, and Robert
Cecil the successor. After that, we'll
take a look inside the Privy Council
itself, and finally, we'll clear up a huge
exam trap about the two Marys.
All right, part one, the Queen's engine
room and managing the realm.
To really understand Elizabeth in England,
you have to realize one fundamental truth.
Yes, Elizabeth was the ultimate boss, and
she set the vision, but she absolutely
could not run the country alone. Just
think about this number for a second.
4 million. Elizabeth had a kingdom of
roughly 4 million people to manage.
For the 16th century, that is a massive
population.
She desperately needed a small, incredibly
dedicated group of ministers to handle,
well, everything from finance and foreign
policy to keeping law and order, running
intelligence, and dealing with the literal
mountain of daily royal mail.
This tight-knit inner circle was her
engine room.
Moving on to part two, let's meet the
first of our heavy hitters, William Cecil,
the steady administrator. When we talk
about staying power, William Cecil is the
gold standard. I mean, look at this
career.
He served from the very first day
Elizabeth became queen in 1558, starting
as principal secretary. By 1571, he was
elevated to Lord Burghley, and a year
later he stepped into the massive role of
Lord Treasurer.
He basically stayed in power until he died
in 1598.
That's a 40-year run at the absolute
pinnacle of Elizabethan politics.
The historian John Guy actually calls
Cecil the indispensable man, and honestly,
he hit the nail on the head. Cecil's
superpower was his administration and his
endless patience. He was that guy who took
meticulous notes, writing up these
incredibly detailed memos where he'd weigh
the pros and cons of literally every
option. As a moderate Protestant, he truly
believed that England's safety relied on
peace abroad and stability at home. And
instead of trying to force the Queen's
hand, he would just wait. He managed her
erratic temperament perfectly by just
being patient until she was ready to
decide.
Now, you're definitely going to want to
highlight this term for your exams, Lord
Treasurer. That means he was the chief
finance minister of the realm.
As Lord Treasurer from 1572 onwards, Cecil
was the money guy.
He constantly pushed back against
expensive foreign wars because he knew the
crown simply couldn't afford them. But
because he was so careful with the purse
strings, when those massive, unavoidable
threats did pop up, like the Spanish
Armada, which we'll get to later, England
actually had the cash to fight back.
Okay, part three. Enter Francis
Walsingham, the spy master.
And wow, is this guy different from Cecil.
It is fascinating to compare these two
side by side because it's basically night
and day.
They were on the same team, sure, but
their vibes were completely opposite.
Cecil was the cautious manager who loved
paperwork.
Walsingham was the paranoid watchman.
Appointed as principal secretary in 1573,
Walsingham was a hardline Protestant. He
was absolutely convinced that Catholic
Europe, especially Spain, was a literal
life or death threat to England.
So, while Cecil used spreadsheets and
patience, Walsingham used spies, double
agents, and intercepted letters.
Walsingham essentially built a 16th
century MI6. It's wild. His most famous
win was unmasking the Babington plot in
1586, and his tradecraft was chillingly
exact.
He'd infiltrate Catholic groups with
informants, snatch their letters, and then
use genius codebreakers like Thomas
Phillips to decrypt the ciphers.
They even figured out how to melt and
reseal wax stamps without anyone noticing.
During the Babington Plot, they didn't
just read the letters, they forged a fake
postscript to trick the plotters into
dropping more names.
This ruthless setup gave him the exact
evidence he needed to convict Mary, Queen
of Scots, and execute her in 1587. We're
going to dive deep into that whole drama
in a future session, I promise. But here
is the craziest part about Walsingham.
The Crown hated spending money on spies.
So get this, Walsingham actually funded a
massive chunk of this intelligence network
out of his own pocket.
He had agents posing as Catholic exiles in
Paris and Rome, and he paid them himself
just to keep their identities totally
hidden from his political rivals back at
court. And because of this, despite
literally saving Queen Elizabeth's life
multiple times, the guy died totally
exhausted and deeply in debt in 1590.
Which brings us to part four, Robert
Cecil, the successor.
So it's 1590, Walsingham is gone, William
Cecil is getting pretty old, and we need a
new generation of leadership. Enter
William's younger son, Robert.
Robert was quite literally bred for this
job.
His dad trained him from boyhood to take
over.
Now, physically, he was quite small and
had a curvature of the spine, but
mentally, the guy was razor sharp and had
a notoriously biting wit.
Elizabeth, who loved a good nickname,
affectionately called him her little elf.
But don't let the nickname fool you.
Robert Cecil was an absolute powerhouse.
By the mid-1590s, he had seamlessly taken
the reins of his father's administrative
duties. And his biggest masterstroke? He
secretly orchestrated the incredibly
delicate negotiations to make sure James
VI of Scotland would peacefully take the
English throne after Elizabeth died. But
it wasn't all smooth sailing.
He had this massive, bitter rivalry with
the Earl of Essex.
Essex felt the Cecils were hogging all the
power, and that bad blood eventually
exploded into the 1601 Essex Rebellion.
That is a wild story for an upcoming
lesson for sure.
All right, part five. Let's step inside
the Privy Council, the room where it all
happened. The thing to remember is that
all these guys, Bergley, Walsingham, the
younger Cecil, these incredibly ambitious,
cutthroat men all had to sit around the
same table and advise the Queen. And it
was an extremely exclusive club.
We're talking about just 19 to 20
handpicked men.
They'd meet two or three times a week, and
this group was the literal steering wheel
of the Elizabethan state. If you wanted
power in England, this was the only room
that mattered. Their workload was just
staggering.
They argued over huge, sweeping issues
like going to war with Spain or how to
enforce the new Protestant religion, but
they were also micromanaging local
problems like who gets a business
monopoly, what to do about a bad wheat
harvest, or how to handle local crime. A
clerk of the council sat there taking
endless notes, and then their decisions
were blasted out across the country as
official royal orders. But right here is
where Elizabeth shows us she was playing
3D chess. She didn't even bother going to
every meeting.
She would just let her ministers yell at
each other, hash out the options, and
bring her the summary. She used them like
a sounding board.
She'd poke holes in their arguments, delay
her decisions, demand more data.
It drove her counselors absolutely crazy.
But it was a brilliant move because it
kept them off balance, stopped them from
uniting against her, and made sure she was
always the one holding the cards. Okay,
part six, the exam trap.
Listen up, guys, because this is crucial.
I need you to burn this into your brain
right now because I see this mistake ruin
grades every single year.
When we talk about Mary in this specific
unit, 99% of the time we mean Mary, Queen
of Scots. She was Elizabeth's Catholic
cousin from the Stuart dynasty, the one
whose letters Walsingham intercepted, the
one who got executed in 1587.
Do not confuse her with Mary I, also known
as Bloody Mary.
Mary I was Elizabeth's half-sister, the
queen before Elizabeth, and she died in
1558. That's a full 10 years before our
depth study even begins.
You have to keep these two straight. So as
we wrap up, I want to leave you with
something to think about while you review
your notes.
The historian Penry Williams summed it up
perfectly.
The council advised, but the queen
decided.
It was this incredible, delicate balancing
act.
She completely relied on the brilliant,
spreadsheet-loving mind of William Cecil
and the dark, paranoid arts of Francis
Walsingham, but she never let them take
over. They were the engine, absolutely,
but Elizabeth always kept her hands firmly
on the wheel. Keep that power dynamic in
the back of your mind as we move through
this unit. Great job today, and I'll see
you in the next one.